welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today we are back with another episode
of the 15 minutes with a mentor series
and this is where we ask some of the
mentors from inside the community seven
questions in 15 minutes i'm very excited
to be joined by jack today
and before we get into the questions
jack if you could introduce yourself to
those that may not know who you are and
then we'll
get through these questions awesome yeah
no pressure
hi guys i'm jack i'm the md of wiser
elite
we are a specialist software sales
recruitment team we've been operating
for almost six years now so i
joined a group called wiser which
specializes in employer branding and
graduate recruitment and i help them
build this new entity
and uh we organically grown it now to a
seven-figure business and uh
over the years kind of be kind of like
doing a bit of a trial and
test kind of process and trying to build
his business out but we're doing a
pretty good job i think and uh yes
great to be part of this and hopefully i
can help i will
fire out me right so what i want to know
first jack
is what was your biggest challenge in
2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
i mean there was loads of challenges
last year right it was uh it was a
pretty tough one i think that the
biggest one
that i faced was like not being in
control so
when the environment is going well you
tend to have a lot of control in terms
of like how you can
fire up the team and it's kind of like
just kind of like getting motivated i
think with last year with what was
happening it was like really
out of my hands in terms of kind of like
their feelings so the
biggest thing there really was like the
people their motivation
how they feel it we weren't in office i
can put my arm around him and just
have that chance or go for that walk
which i would usually do if i feel like
someone's down or
needs a bit of a bump so i'd say that's
probably the
the biggest challenge that i faced and
um
we're getting through it now like we've
obviously kind of found a bit of a
rhythm
um and i've learned how to deal with
that but i think which is the lack of
control
to start yeah so what
work working from home tip could you
share with other recruiters listening to
this that you feel has had a sort of
real positive impact on your
productivity
when working from home
skill works i think it's having a start
and end of day so
i found myself working up to like 9 10
o'clock at night because there's nothing
else to do and
the next completely knackers and i'm not
in the right headspace so
the days where i've had a clear plan and
i mean everyone will tell you this even
if you're not working from home having a
clear plan and having a structure this
is what i'm going to do
nine talk six or whatever hours you work
was um
a big changer for me we also changed up
a few things which is like our meetings
like having a bit of walk and talk
rather than just having
um chats like this over zoom because
um it can be a bit obviously kind of
tiring doing over and over again it's
just trying to change up
massively helps so i'd say there were
two things it's like having a start end
of the day and then just changing up how
you're trying to communicate
with everyone but also even how you're
communicating with candidates and
clients some candidates when i'm doing a
prep call i'm like
okay i'm going to do this on a walk if
it's a nice day which is quite tough to
find in january
yeah nice so i'd be interested to know
like over the last 12 months what's been
the most effective way for you guys to
win business
so it massively bounced back for us our
financial year starts in april and we
saw
in that first queue and second cube like
we were doing 40 of our number it was
really really tough and
obviously everything dropped off at the
start and it kind of slowly bounced back
all of the client wins that we saw
towards uh q3 which was
october november december a lot of it
which is from all of the long-term
partnerships we've had
i'd say we probably another 15 new
client wins
but um a lot of it was just down to
people knowing who we were and i think
that's because we played this long-term
approach with our clients and
we never tried to do a quick win here or
there we never tried to
treat a candidate badly if we can't help
them always give them the update on
what's going on
so a lot of those came back to us and
gave us business and
the ones that we found we had um
want new clients we have new logos know
what to perform
it was just like yeah it was just candid
spec-ins that we just saw that they were
hiring at this time but it just raised
investments or
something happened there was an event in
their business and was like
we just be smart about their messaging
it wasn't just a generic message it was
like
seeing this is happening and i'm
guessing you're gonna be looking for x y
and z's
here's a good profile that i think you
should consider would you be open to a
chat
this time next week and we'll even
that's up as well
um but what i did what i did notice is
that
previously we didn't really have much
focus around obedience of the number of
messages going out each week or number
of calls
and so we had much more structure but it
was more important to us because we
needed to win business such
again nice interesting so
be interesting to know what what habit
of hobby did you start in 2020 that
you're going to continue in 2021
that's a good question um
i'd say like i mean it's running
and getting out a little bit more like i
mean it's
um where all my ideas come from it's
where you know i have really good time
to think and be on my own
even when you're on your own in the
house making a partner and stuff you
never really only run but getting out
and running and stuff
really made a difference so that's
something that i think this year i'm
going to try and keep in touch
as long as i'm not getting injured which
i have at the moment so
any big run any big run goals this year
because this has come up a lot it's
definitely helped me
run and i want to keep it but any big
goals you want to share
well steven marathon i signed up for the
brighton mountain which is
so probably the most important question
jack what do you think is better the
first coffee in the morning
or the first pint post work on a friday
coffee
yes i'm glad that conviction i like that
i'm definitely confident awesome
right seconds last i love good point
after work but i always regret it
um right second so so this question is
slightly different it's a scenario that
i want to sort of hear
how you would approach it so scenario is
a particular client that you've had on
your target client list for a long
period of time
during that time there's been several
touch points so i know you guys
do different things from round tables to
webinars to podcast etc but during that
time
they may have attended one of your
events they may have listened to a
podcast
you may have even dropped them a note on
linkedin or an email but through your
candidate network
you managed to get one of the hiring
managers contact details at this target
client so
you call them they pick up they say
hello who is this and
just want to hear how you'd approach
that conversation
sure um it tends to always keep it short
and sweet and never go into it with like
i'm trying to sell to someone so
generally i would have a an opener or
you know a referral by someone saying
hey i was put in touch with you by x y
or zed or hey
notice this event again that happens um
or you came to event or whatever it may
be so make sure that first line is
strong
and then say like it'd be good to have
like 20 seconds just to run through
while i'm calling and then they would
then say okay interesting oh yes i've
heard of you guys or
whatever it may be and then i would go
into asking questions about
obviously the current situation with
hiring so i'll say
where um we help software tech companies
who
are recruiting sdrs or accounting sex
and sales leaders
are you looking to hire in the next 30
days or so and then
if they respond and say yes or no then
obviously i look to try and move to the
next kind of
session which would be try to get a
meeting or try to you know
do a full up ourselves by the time but
i'll never try and go into that meeting
with just like
bombard them with information and i
would always like
sweet so making sure that it's 30 60
seconds is
quite clear about what you're doing and
the reason for that yeah no i really
like
i've definitely use that where you say
um
this will take 20 seconds or have you
got 20 seconds yes or no and if i say
yes then
yeah you sort of just you've then been
given um
the green light right to do it and you
feel a bit more comfortable with it so
that that's always helped me as well to
be fair
so last question so i want you to sort
of imagine
really this may be something that you
you've done with your team internally
but just wanting to imagine that
i'm a recruiter that has set goals for
2021
completely convinced i'm gonna have a
better year than i did in 2020
feeling motivated and i just want to
sort of hear what your advice be
would uh would be to recruiters listen
to this
that you think would give us the best
chance of actually
achieving the goals that we've set um
we'd love to hear that from you
so jvco is quite interesting i looked
back to my goals last year and the year
before and
last year i didn't achieve any of those
goals because obviously there's a lot of
change with what happened
there so um i don't want to come at this
with
you know this is how you hit goals
because i'm definitely on that journey
of like what do i need to be doing to
make sure i'm consistently hitting those
but
i can't let you know why i've missed
goals in the past and why i've achieved
goals in the past and kind of give a bit
of a breakdown maybe
someone could pick up something from
that moving forward as well yeah that
sounds good
so reasons why i failed i think being
unrealistic with the goal
so maybe the goal is too ambitious or
the time we're trying to do it is
unrealistic
so you know trying to do a million pound
in a quarter
is a great goal but you know is it
realistic and so i've set a few of those
in the past and like
actually that wasn't achievable so
something like some of that's considered
when you look at your goals for this
year is realistic
um you know the reason why having an
achieved goal is not putting enough
effort into it so what's the motivation
behind that goal
do you really care about it like is it
something going to get up every single
day and trying to work towards or is it
just like a little bit of a fad because
sounds good yeah so make sure that's in
place
um and the reason why i haven't hit
goals is obviously something's changed
like maybe pandemic or you know
um the desk has changed direction or
someone's left the business whatever it
may be like they're their reasons why i
haven't hit goals in the past
why i have achieved goals is that i
haven't had too many
so to achieve is that i only focus on
that and maybe one other
so look at your list of goals make sure
that you've got
you know a select few that you really
really care about you're motivated
behind
and then i think you'll probably have a
more success rate of trying to hit those
and do this for this year
and also the goals i have here i had
early momentum with
so um don't try and make a goal which is
going to be over 12 months try and break
it down so you can
take that box in the first week or take
a box in the first month that momentum
will really help you to try and
you know achieve that over a large goal
so either break it down or make it
smaller so you can feel that momentum
initially as well um and making it
visible
so the goals i've achieved have been
quite clear whether they've been sitting
on my laptop but they've been sitting
um you know if i'll be on my on my
notebook
that's something that's obviously really
important because you have to put action
towards them every single day it can't
be something to pick up
like once every two months old like oh
crap i need to get outside for my
marathon so
you work towards the things i've never
had really is someone helping me
to be accountable i can only imagine
that's gonna you know
gonna be important something to you know
keep pressure on you as
either your manager or colleague or
friend and something to
um you know just kind of bounce off
ideas if things are going down
struggling
so i have people in my team who are
working towards goals and make sure i
check in with them
every fortnight and like okay we have
these quarterly goals
what's happening here what's up in the
past two weeks what are you gonna do in
the next two weeks so it doesn't get too
long
um and in the past i've had situations
where we've had court sleep reviews
we haven't spoke about a goal for the
whole three months and like actually i
really missed it and that was just a
waste of their time in my time so
something to bear in mind yeah and i
love that that was 50 minutes of a
mentor
thank you appreciate it bro